wo ist dein weg
auch immer vor sich
oliver barth lisa weil die woche stellen
diese ja das machen ja klar
wie geht es ihnen es geht mir gut sagt
hallo haben sie dieses tasche gefunden
leider nicht aber ich habe den
fahrradladen gefunden was ja es gibt
zumindest eine jahreszahl ist der
fahrradladen hat ja das ist sie der
fahrplan ist in der adalbert stifter
straße 43 das ist im zentrum in der nähe
vom arbeitsamt und ich war da das ist
der laden auf dem foto ja und wie kommen
wir da hin
zuerst fällt ihr mit dem bus bis zum
grafen platz mit dem bus zum greifen nah
den kenne ich und weiter geht ihr über
den grafen platz und kommt in die
kruppstraße in die kruppstraße ja genau
geht die crew straße entlang überquert
die große kreuzung dein gegen theater
vorbei und an der nächsten ampel rechts
weißt du ja ja das ist nicht weit und
theater vorbei und dann die zweite ampel
rechts noch mal ihren papa schon okay
ich schaue melina also gehen sie bis zum
grafen platz liegen sie dann links in
die kreisstraße überqueren sie die
schlossstraße und biegen sie an der
nächsten kreuzung rechts in die
adalbert-stifter-straße okay